So there are seven main
petals that form the core of
The Living Building Challenge.
The first has to do with place,
understanding the climate
and impacts that a building
may have on its site.
The second has to do
with the responsible use
of energy on site
as well as water.
Then there's
the use of materials.
And here
the focus is to eliminate all of
these chemicals and materials
that are known
to be destructive,
either in terms of toxicity,
energy, or depletion
of resources around the world.
And lastly,
there's a whole slew
of really interesting
criteria, including happiness
and well-being, equity,
and this wonderful category
called biophilic design.
And that really opens up
an aspirational aspect
of The Living Building
Challenge,
which is to connect humans
with their broader ecology.